i'm tyrus i'm liz clayman i'm greg
jarrett
and this is the fox news rundown
friday may 14 2021 i'm lisa brady
if you're fully vaccinated you can stop
wearing a mask
most of the time new guidance from the
cdc that's been a long time coming when
you see people wearing masks and doors
it's illogical and i think right now
you're seeing a political establishment
saying
look if we continue along these
draconian guidelines that we put out
we're going to lose all the credibility
of the public i'm chris foster
the news on jobs has been mixed lately
with fewer jobs created last month but
fewer people being laid off from the
jobs they have
in some cases employers can't find
anyone to hire
look there are obviously problems and
when you've had this
severe a public health crisis and you've
had this severe and economic crisis
you're gonna see bumps and i'm tammy
bruce i've got the final word on the fox
news rundown
after more than a year of wearing masks
this is music to the ears of millions of
americans
once you are fully vaccinated two weeks
after your last dose
you can shed your mass the cdc director
dr rochelle wolenski says that means
doing the things you had stopped
doing because of the pandemic outdoor
and indoor activities large and small
without a mask and without social
distancing
we have all longed for this moment
when we can get back to some sense of
normalcy
in the rose garden a few hours later an
unmasked president biden hailing the
announcement
as a great milestone and he credits
americans for doing what he calls their
patriotic duty
encouraging others to follow after a
year of hard work and so much sacrifice
the rule is very simple get vaccinated
or wear a mask until you do
the cdc also says if you're vaccinated
and are exposed to covid you don't have
to get tested
however any federal state or local rules
still apply
including businesses that require masks
or workplace rules for employees
and even for fully vaccinated people the
cdc still recommends a mask
in crowded indoor settings including
buses
airplanes and hospitals but things like
getting a haircut
going to a movie the gym bars and
restaurants or
attending church even at full capacity
are now considered
safe without a mask if you're vaccinated
the cdc
and the biden administration and they're
one they're one entity
they're responding to public frustration
dr marty mccary is a professor of
surgery and health policy at the johns
hopkins university school of medicine
fox news medical contributor and author
of the price we pay
right now people are getting really
angry and they're angry at outdated
guidance and they're outdated
restrictions
they know we're not based on science so
what you're seeing is a response to
public frustration
when enough of us are out there on a
number of platforms
pointing out how there's no science to
support these
restrictions i think you're seeing a
political establishment right now
worried about re-elections
well at the very least the president did
acknowledge
uh or seem to acknowledge this week that
it's you know if you want to give an
incentive for more people to continue to
get vaccinated
then let them know they won't need the
mask that's right telling people they
need to wear masks
indoors or kids need to wear them
outdoors contradicts
every other message we're sending and
that is the outdoors is safe
it dissipates the air supplies virus
instantly the risk outdoors is
minuscule and it really sort of
undermines the ability
of people to trust the vaccine because
vaccine is
makes you bulletproof in preventing
death and hospitalization
from any variant of the vat of the virus
you see people wearing masks indoors
it's illogical and i think right now
you're seeing a political establishment
saying
look if we continue along these
draconian guidelines that we put out
we're going to lose all the credibility
of the public i guess the
what you just said about deaths and
hospitalizations is really the key
because i was going to ask you know if
they're still not 100
sure that the vaccine prevents
transmission
then why do this now especially with
more contagious variants out there but i
guess the bottom line is if you're
vaccinated
even if you do still get covet it's just
not going to have the consequences that
it would have
people have a completely distorted
perception of risk right now in the
united states and the surveys are
showing that showing that even among
vaccinated
people they don't feel safe not wearing
a mask and it shows how distorted that
public
perception is now if if you want to um
ask like what what can we do better or
differently
it's pretty clear to me that we've got
to be in step with the american people
right now
these guidelines are completely out of
step well here's a hypothetical
for you let's say i'm vaccinated but i
have an elderly person in my family
who still isn't for whatever reason
should i still wear a mask to reduce the
risk of catching the virus and being
asymptomatic maybe and passing it on to
them
yeah i think if you feel more
comfortable with a very high risk person
at home who's unvaccinated or vulnerable
if adding that tiny added small
percentage increase
in reducing the transmission risk is
something of interest
then i would say do it the problem is
we've got
utility workers outside on the job on a
hot summer day
wearing a mask we've got high school
track
athletes passing out from carbon dioxide
inhalation toxicity
from wearing a mask and there's harm and
no benefit
so if somebody has it has any concern
and they want to wear masks go ahead
that's exactly how our society is
supposed to work
the problem is so many people rely on
the cdc for every single thing they
do and if they say something like kids
have to wear a mask
at outdoor summer camps or people a
small group of people
indoors all of whom are fully vaccinated
have to continue to wear masks
then people see through that and and
they lose a lot of credibility
so now we've got certainly more freedom
than there was
um but they are
uh still saying that indoors in a
crowded place like a bus or an airplane
people should still be masking up or a
hospital for that matter
is that clear enough is there fine print
on masks
now clear enough and is that warranted
so the reason they're doing that is
because
people who have to marshal masks
at those places at airports and at
um on buses they can't
tell who's vaccinated or not so by
asking everybody
in those particular locations to still
wear masks
in the universal way it avoids the
issue of having to produce proof of
vaccination
so it's really basically another option
now they're going to need to drop that
pretty quickly and the reason is because
about 8 out of 10 adults in the united
states have immunity
when you go to a restaurant when you go
to a
sports event and you're sitting outdoors
when you're in a stadium when you're at
a meeting
at the office eight out of ten people
are barriers for the trans
for the virus to transmit or jump around
that's basically kind of what herd
immunity is and we've always said when
you're at 70 to 85
of people in a location of a population
that has immunity you significantly
reduce transmission
that's why infection rates are
plummeting across the country today
and the reason i say 8 out of 10 and not
6 out of 10 which is the number of
people
who who've been vaccinated is about half
of unvaccinated people have
natural immunity from prior infections
something that the current
administration
and the cdc and dr falchi are still very
dismissive of
and unfairly dismissed about natural
immunity is a complete
game changer it changes the equation
of how you get to population immunity
because if you don't acknowledge natural
immunity
the only way to get to 85 immunity is
through vaccine mandates and vaccinating
every kid
and demonizing those who are hesitant
even though some have a good reason to
be hesitant
we're about to have more people
vaccinated because
kids ages 12 to 15 are now allowed to
get the pfizer
vaccine should children be getting it
what do parents need to know about that
well look i think a 12 to 15 year old is
physiologically
similar to an adult so i have no
concerns of the vaccine safety and i'm
confident that it will be efficacious
for a kid who has a chronic condition
for example a kid who is overweight i
would recommend they get it
we know that 78 of all hospitalizations
are in people who are overweight or
obese
or and the remaining are in people with
some other comorbid conditions it's very
hard for this virus
as i've said from day one of this
pandemic
it is very hard for this virus to hurt
somebody
young and healthy it's happened but it's
exceedingly rare
and so for healthy kids the question is
is it worth getting it
i would say as i recently outlined in
the washington post
in a piece with nicole sapphire is there
can be still
a reasonable justification for
getting a child vaccinated even if
they're young and healthy
because the systemic inflammatory
syndrome
still affects a lot of kids there's
probably been ten thousand
cases of that in the united states over
the pandemic
people get the infection and then the
kids get the affection then weeks later
we get this inflammatory response
if you saw that inflammatory response in
the icu upfront and personal
it's it's not pretty it's it can be
painful for the kids and it can have
some consequences
so i'm not concerned about the risk of
death in young healthy kids
but there is a reasonable risk of
inflammatory
syndrome which the vaccine can prevent
are they getting the same
dose and expecting the same kinds of
side effects
as adults with the pfizer vaccine
this side effects we really have not
powered the study to look at the side
effect profile but
we can use the extrapolation that a
12 to 15 year old is physiologically
similar to an adult and
they are with other vaccines and in the
early results
from the trials we know that the safety
profile is very high
so it is dose dependent it's it's weight
dependent
and i feel confident in the safety of
the pfizer and modern vaccine kids
i think it's really just a personal
choice i think
most important though lisa we need to
respect people's decisions
if they decide to get it or not get it
let's let that
let's let it be their decision we we
have to stop
at every age level demonizing people
right now
as if they're the barrier to reaching
herd immunity in the country
we don't need them because half of
people unvaccinated have natural
immunity for prior infection
we need to respect people's individual
choices
what are the chances though that mask
mandates or
similar guidelines could return this
fall
how do we avoid having to mask up again
i am concerned that they were going to
see restrictions in the fall
like i have no problems if people want
to choose individually to wear a mask in
the fall because of a concern they
might have or maybe risk factors maybe
they just like wearing a mask let people
do whatever they want to do
we probably can look to asia and what
they've been doing
for the last few decades to say here's a
good practice
wear a mask if you're have any symptoms
or you are around somebody with symptoms
or you have risk factors or you're just
concerned otherwise
um you don't need to and so you do see
selective masking
in in countries around the world that
have basically been practicing good
hygiene during influenza
asia got burned during sarge one during
that pandemic
they learned that it's aerosolized virus
that it's airborne and that
masks help that's why they've been
wearing masks for a long time that's
probably why
they've done so well in many of these
outbreaks
this feels for now though in the us like
turning a corner in this pandemic should
it is that how
how it should feel yeah we are turning
the corner i mean cases are plummeting
and if you look at regionally the
outbreaks that were happening mostly
among younger people in michigan
they've mostly resolved i mean michigan
is down over 50
in the last month so we're seeing cases
down across the board
even in countries that are still
experiencing outbreaks we're starting to
see those numbers start to show signs of
turning over
so i think people should get good news
you know i heard the cdc director say
you know there's some good news but the
risk of variance could undo things
why would you say that people need hope
right now and there's no evidence that
any variant has
ever any of the hundreds of variants has
ever evaded
the vaccine's protective effect in
preventing death
and hospitalization so i think people
should be optimistic right now i'm very
hopeful myself
dr marty mccary thank you as always for
your time
thanks lisa
[Music]
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
we're seeing the fewest weekly layoffs
now since the start of the coronavirus
pandemic shutdowns last march
473 000 last week according to the labor
department
that's still nearly twice as many as
before the coronavirus pandemic and
there are still more job seekers than
job openings out there
president biden says people should at
least be looking for work we're going to
make it clear that anyone collecting
unemployment
who is offered a suitable job
must take the job or lose their
unemployment benefits
a lot of restaurant owners for example
say they're short on staff because
people won't take those jobs
some republican governors are trying to
end any labor shortages by ending access
to extra federal unemployment aid 300
bucks a week
next month south carolina governor henry
mcmaster tells fox there are a lot of
help wanted signs up in his
state they're looking for people to work
and the people just won't come to work
because they're getting as much money or
or more in some cases by staying home
the white house says it's other factors
keeping people home but it's still a
concern
oh absolutely i mean and obviously the
bike administration is very sensitive to
this
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday the president came out this week
and said look if you get offered a job
you have to take it now
i honestly i don't know how they can
know whether or not you've been offered
a job
but it's it's an indication that they
don't want people
turning down jobs because of the very
real fact that they can make which
just seems like a bad situation you can
literally make more money not working
than working
yeah i mean so far something like 11
states as we speak are turning down
these enhanced unemployment federal
benefits 300 bucks a week
in addition to the state benefits now
look i've read several studies
showing that getting unemployment aid
doesn't discourage job searches but i
just can't square that
for really low-paying jobs where you
literally do make you know close to or
as much as or more than you were making
before yeah i know it's it's it's a
problem
and you know you do also have to say to
yourself when
the economy is going and such great guns
or at least was until this last month
and you've got
an annualized rate of gdp growth of six
percent
do you still need these enhanced
unemployment benefits it you know and
maybe
yes people might have to take a little
bit less and i can unders
you know it's easy for you or me to say
but on the other hand the idea of
getting people back to work and getting
the economy
going is a kind of virtuous circle that
it seems to me you want to encourage
yeah on the other hand it's also
industry by industry if you were laid
off
from an 80 000 a year job you might not
want to go work at starbucks
and you might figure i'm better off
staying at home no and there are other
aspects as well you've got the child
care situation which is
that you know some particularly women
who've been really hard-hit
uh who want to go back in the workforce
but have to stay home for the kids
particularly if the kids the schools
haven't reopened
you know there are there are absolutely
a number of factors in this
but you would hope that really smart
people would sit there
and try to figure out you know what what
government policies to a certain degree
they're things that are beyond our
control but what government policies
can we either continue enhance or
cut out to get people back to work and
you know for good paying jobs speaking
to the school issue the american
federation of teachers president now
says look schools have to be open in the
fall
five days a week in person kids 12 and
up can get vaccinated now
so that should really help at least by
the fall that's not going to help
restaurant owners in the summer
but you've got to think by september
we're closer to
fuller employment look there are
obviously problems and when you've had
this
severe a public health crisis and you've
had this severe and economic crisis
you're going to see bumps and you know
one of them for instance is inflation i
saw a fascinating study today
that you know with there was this big
bump in inflation
uh annualized rate of 4.8 percent
in the last month well in fact if you
did a steady curve
or a steady graph we're at two percent
inflation
from a year ago in march or april
when the pandemic started to now and one
of the reasons you're seeing this big
inflationary spike is not because the
prices have gone up so much it's that
the prices went down
a year ago so it makes the prices seem
higher so you know you have to assume
that there are going to be some spikes
having said that it's pretty good news
one of the newsletters i read showed
they do a map and they have it in
different colors are cobig cases going
up or covered cases going down
and it's a sea of gray which is
copied cases going down in the vast
majority of states around the country
you know and the only thing i would say
in that regard is
more people please get vaccinated it
i've done it you know everybody i know
has done it
safe uh reliable and
you know we need to get back to normal
and then the more people that get
vaccinated
the quicker that will happen uh let's
moving on moving on to the middle east
for a minute the israelis and
palestinian troubles are on fire again
president biden happens to be in the
white house this time and but he says we
need to stand with the israeli people
some people on the left say that's too
far that we should have more sympathy
for the palestinians that there's an
occupation
republicans say biden's being too weak
here again it's a tough or no win
situation for any american president to
be in what can he do
i i you know this is one i i know that
there's this sort of talking point among
republicans oh there are all these
crises and you know there are
but to blame joe biden for what's going
on
between the palestinians and the
israelis i mean to me it would be like
blaming donald trump and saying wait a
minute mr president you had the abraham
accords
why are we having fighting in the middle
east you said that you'd put an end to
it
i mean this is a hot spot it's been a
hot spot for years
there's a lot of internal issues here uh
you know first of all there's just the
facts on the ground which is that these
israelis were going to evict some
palestinians from east jerusalem
uh there was a fight on the temple mount
of the al-aqsa mosque
uh hamas is trying to show that it
really stands up for the palestinians
more than the
more mainstream group fatah benjamin
netanyahu was just about to be
kicked out as prime minister and
opposition government i'm not blaming it
on any single person but to say that
this is joe biden's fault
strikes me as absurd yeah well i wasn't
implying it was his fault i just don't
again
know what an american president can even
do here
for all the reasons you just mentioned
it's all for american presidents are
supposed to somehow jump into the fray
when these things happen
yeah and uh look you want to do
everything you can to
lessen tensions to try to get a
ceasefire but
you know there are just facts on the
ground and
you know it is an occupation and uh by
the israelis of palestinian territories
and on the other hand
the palestinians you know there's an old
phrase have never missed an opportunity
to miss an opportunity
so there's enough blame to go around on
both sides
and uh there are real limits to what any
u.s president can do
let me wrap it up with liz cheney she's
now out as the number three republican
in the house i'm not sure
though that many people who are not in
dc politics or in our business
much care chuck grassley rick scott have
said that seriously not a single
constituent has asked them about this
even republicans
i you know look i i'm not saying that
i'm not going to say that they're not
telling the truth i don't know whether a
constituent is asked
i think people care because i think that
there is a real issue
on both sides incidentally in the
republican party about
donald trump and whether this needs to
be the trump party or whether it needs
to go back to first principles
because trump took it in a lot of
different directions when it came to
trade when it came to
role in the in the world a lot of other
issues
and you know i i think it's a it's a
it's a real
question and and people have to be
concerned if for no other reason are
interested
i think the question is to donald
trump's hold of the party which seems to
be
still pretty strong but definitely not
as strong as it was six months ago if
you
if you believe the polls in terms of
people that are very strongly for them
uh is interesting we're going to be
talking to liz cheney on on
sunday she's going to be our live top
guest and you know one of the questions
i want to ask her is it's fine i don't
think anybody or
most people have a beef with you having
the feelings and saying what you have
about donald trump but when you're
in a position of leadership and the
republicans are so close to taking back
the house
you want to emphasize the differences in
the party or do you want to emphasize
the unity in the party when it comes to
con you know taking on
the biden agenda so i mean i think there
are legitimate questions to ask was
jenny i also
want to ask her about her endgame here
she's a very smart resourceful woman but
if she has any thoughts about running
for president against donald trump or
the trump base
in 2024 that's going to be quite an
obstacle for her
chris wallace the host of fox news
sunday chris will be uh watching that
interview whatever else you've got going
on sunday thanks for coming on
thank you chris
[Music]
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life
politics and entertainment subscribe now
on foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
national school nurses day was observed
this week and the state of maine is
making sure school nurses know
they're appreciated instead of picking
one nurse to give its school nurse of
the year honor to
maine is giving it to all of them
governor janet mills a democrat and the
maine department of education
said wednesday they and the maine
association of school nurses are
recognizing
all the nurses and schools since the
pandemic has taxed resources at school
districts throughout the state
they said school nurses have had to take
on new responsibilities to help keep
students healthy and schools safe
that's a point backed up by the national
association of school nurses which has
more than 17 thousand members nationwide
school nurses have been taking on
additional duties during the pandemic
like covet 19 testing
contact tracing and giving vaccinations
to students and staff members
so here's a big thank you to school
nurses who are doing the essential work
of keeping kids safe and healthy
which is good news tanya j powers fox
news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
tammy bruce
what's on your mind people the world
over have rejected the concept of a
vaccine passport
because of the obvious violations of
personal freedom and obscene government
overreach
this hasn't mattered to the tiny tyrants
running the global establishment
so they just use euphemisms when
referring to requiring people
to prove that they've been vaccinated in
order to enjoy being allowed to
participate in normal daily life
case in point is new york state governor
andrew cuomo announcing new covet 19
seating regulations
for the opening of all outdoor venues
like baseball stadiums
the vaccinated the man whose covet 19
policies are responsible for the deaths
of at least 15
000 new yorkers tells us will be allowed
to sit in certain
quote normal sections at stadiums
without social distancing
the unvaccinated however will be
segregated in different sections where
there will be social distancing
keep in mind this is for people sitting
in a massive outdoor environment
moreover everyone regardless of
vaccination status will still have to
wear a mask
as i noted on fox nation this is
effectively a vaccine passport
where if you're unvaccinated you'll be
sitting in the back of the bus
keep in mind this is about segregating
groups of americans
based on whether or not they've complied
with what the government sanctimoniously
announces is best for you
even though there is no law requiring
you to do so
the absurdity of this is stunning and
the media is reporting on it
as though it is perfectly reasonable and
in the case of the new york times
they describe it as a perk for the
vaccinated
too inconvenient to mention or discuss
is what it means for the unvaccinated
or those who refuse to reveal private
medical information
this arrangement requires citizens to
reveal to strangers either the
government
and or a private entity they're
protected in private health status
people who do not comply will be
segregated revealing to everyone
that either you've chosen not to be
vaccinated or you in the eyes of tiny
tyrants
are a troublemaker who refuses to
cooperate
the ease with which mr cuomo is
resorting to segregation
is more than troubling it's dangerous
and offensive black americans have for
good reason
a level of concern and suspicion about
the government making demands and
issuing promises
regarding health the u.s public health
services
quote tuskegee study of untreated
syphilis in the negro male
end quote which ended only in 1973
involved watching the progression of
syphilis and black men while telling
them they were receiving treatment
when they were not bottom line our
government used black americans as
guinea pigs in a horrific medical
experiment
after 40 years it stopped only because a
whistleblower
exposed the scheme now in progressive
21st century new york
we're being told that people who have
refused to have an experimental vaccine
injected into them will be segregated in
a certain area can only sit in a certain
place
buy food from certain counters and
socialize away from other people
all because of who they are and their
refusal to
behave we have a history of this but it
appears mr cuomo could care less
these issues are obvious so it's
reasonable to conclude mr cuomo is doing
this to manipulate and shame people
into getting the vaccine we know this is
a deeply personal decision
for each person there are different
reasons why they may be hesitant
yet with close to 50 percent of the
american population
being fully vaccinated only the
unvaccinated are at risk
and they can choose to adapt accordingly
the como administration has been exposed
as not using science to direct the
decisions and actions his administration
takes if he did we would not have had
the mass death covet 19 catastrophe
at nursing homes all of the scandals he
is facing
are based on abusing people and abusing
the power of his office
for a man who has not considered the
death toll of his actions
during covet 19 why should we expect him
to respect the civil rights of other
human beings
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
new from the fox news podcast network my
name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com